every single time it was different and
we must have done it 50 times because
everyone in the room was like there's no
way he can do it differently spider-man
spider-man does whatever a spider-man
wants there's something about the role
that just demands a lot of improv check
out these improvised scenes from all of
your favorite spidey movies number one
when the tears come streaming down your
face with laughter because of this
confusing moment
see no way home or haven't seen it this
isn't much of a spoiler it's talked
about in the trailer turns out alfred
molina confused the heck out of tom
holland with this one i am so confused
right now there's a line where i say i
think i can fix you and then he goes
fixed like a dog because every time he
said it i was like why does he keep ad
living in this line about
fixing dogs why this confused tom so
much is that they don't use that phrase
in england he was confused about the
snipping he was like why does he keep
doing it
number two we wonder if tom still has
the video on his phone tom holland and
his brother harry improvised a fight
scene for far from home the scene where
tom is banging into the bell came from
the genius of the holland family and
when i say we previously we shot it on
my phone and director john watts liked
it so much they kept it in the final
film banging into the thing and then
sliding and then banging into it again
yeah that was that was awesome number
three the costume looks great for the
costume party
imagine being jacob battle on and not
being told what you're about to walk in
on and then it turns out it's a
half-naked spider-man or should we say
night monkey and mj trying to sneak a
peek that's exactly what battle on dealt
with when he improvised this moment in
far from home that's a lot to process
all of a sudden
number four
never meet your heroes they'll only
disappoint you that's how peter parker
felt when he thought tony stark was
leaning in for a hug but turns out he
was just trying to get the door for the
kid did you know this moment was
improvised by tom holland i think i just
tried to hug him i just thought it would
be funny if i hugged him sure you did
tom good cover story number five up up
and uh wrong universe toby the internet
really spun those toby maguire memes out
of control for a bit there huh
go with did you know pretty much this
entire scene was improvised
if you can recall he uses superman's
famous catchphrase
and shazams
number six three more movies three more
movies while the first hug shared
between peter and tony was insanely
awkward the last one before peter parker
blipped was totally heartbreaking
hollins
was improvised well sort of so it's not
that amazing of an ad-lib but it kind of
is because tom holland has said that he
will repeat his lines in his head to
bring up emotion and you know how he
said sort of well he did improvise it
during one take but that isn't the take
they went with it sparked a great idea
though and then we reworked the scene
and then this was born number seven
daily bugle reports jk simmons casted to
play spider-man in reboot here's a
personal favorite improv moment
what we love about this deleted scene is
it's very telling of a deeper side of jk
simmons character he doesn't really hate
spidey he just loves drama he sells
drama he loves spider-man because
spider-man makes him money and is there
perhaps an element of jealousy in there
too
number eight somebody needs to wash his
mouth out with soap samuel l jackson's
hilarious moment of improvisation was so
great it ended up in the trailer for far
from home please you've been to space
which is a bit surprising given that he
swears in it but it's totally hilarious
and sometimes you just need somebody to
be real with you
number nine
sorry for reminding you remember the day
your childhood was ruined when you
learned what a pelvic thrust was yeah we
do too in great detail thanks to toby
maguire he was always totally aware that
the intention of the scene was for the
symbiote to make him think he's cool
while he's actually acting like a total
dork and so on the day of filming he
gifted the world with a memory we'd
rather forget and turns out this scene
is actually one of the only symbiote
scenes director rainey liked filming
because he didn't even want to include
venom in the third installment
number 10 everything is riding up this
scene in the elevator happened over
about 25 takes if the whole scene seems
awkward it rides up in the crotch a
little bit too that's because it is the
actors weren't given any lines to say
and they had to improvise their way
through the thing never meet your heroes
kids it only disappoints or think more
like mj if you expect disappointment
then you can never really be
disappointed although many mcu actors
have gone on record to say their
costumes are super uncomfortable so
these two really nailed the actor's life
experience
number 11. maybe not in front of her
family dude andrew garfield and emma
stone were more than an on-screen couple
during their time shooting the amazing
spider-man movies their on-screen
chemistry is undeniable in this moment
where peter parker plants one on gwen
stacy in front of the whole crowd well
that smooch was totally improvised did
you find that same look of surprise on
your face that aunt may had on hers
because we totally did
number 12.
marissa tomei and tom holland's
relationship really developed quite
naturally and this version of aunt may
is probably the most underrated
character in all of the mcu
aunt may is hilarious and so is marissa
tomei because she improvised that entire
scene in the thai restaurant stu larby
not larvae enough
we could always do with an extended cut
of larb
number 13 and we don't mean ruffalo if
you didn't already have an insane amount
of respect for rdj before you will now
he was really looking out for the new
guy aka tom holland after he missed his
mark instead of calling cut rdj went
full pro actor on the noob and
graciously improvised this line i'm
gonna sit here so you move the leg tom
holland is no noob anymore though and
has really swung into his own but the
dynamic between the two is just so
genuine and robert downey jr knew he
could trust holland to follow along
since he threw him some curveballs at
the audition okay yeah i love adventure
number 14. the spidey suit is for
stopping petty crime not to escape in
spaceships didn't you know that one of
our favorite things about robert downey
jr and tom holland is their ability to
improvise off of each other and rdj has
spent so much time as stark basically
being the character irl that the improv
comes so naturally to him i'm back up no
you're still away the adults are talking
number 15 improv is an important skill
for all of the spider-man actors the
cast shot this scene at the iconic
london tower again and again because
their improvising skills were on fire
we can only imagine what hilarity the
other shots held we would love to see
that but we trust that the editors
picked the best moments
number 16 wrong universe keaton
unfortunately this awesome bit got cut
tom holland said that michael keaton
made a reference to one of his past
characters when vulture wondered why
spider-man would save him peter parker
said because i'm spider-man and keaton
supposedly ad-libbed
i'm batman number 17 we only wish
mysterio was good tom holland and jake
gyllenhaal immediately had a special
bond on set which led to some major
paranoia for tom a lot of the script got
changed to make mysterio softer by the
will of holland and gyllenhaal which
made mysterio's ultimate betrayal even
more shocking jake has a bit of a
reputation for being a method actor i
got really worried that he was just
being my friend because he's a method
actor and then at some point he was
gonna switch and they were concerned
that after the movie was over that he'd
just be awful number 18 our favorite
on-screen couple jacob battalon and gary
rice mostly created their on-screen
relationship together they had a lot of
space for improv how cool would it be to
be able to basically create your own
character for a movie especially when
your character is the comedic relief
honestly these scenes must have been
some of the most fun to film number 19.
stay out of my room dad this hilarious
scene when andrew garfield's spider-man
comes through the window into gwen
stacy's room got the best improvised
moment what we love about it is how much
the scene feels like hiding your
intimacy with your boyfriend from your
dad when he offers her hot cocoa and
recalls her fantasy to be to live at a
chocolate house she says well that's
impractical
and fattening
the double door slam is what gets us
number 20. we're not really sure the
resemblance between these two but we
won't argue with stan poor stan lee was
kept on such a tight leash for this
scene he was forced to stay silent
despite wanting to say oh dostoyevsky
he's like the russian stan lee if you
don't know who that is he wrote crime
and punishment which really isn't
comic-like at all the horror and gothic
elements to the story really keep it out
of the realm of superheroes saving the
day and that's 20 of our favorite
improvised moments from spider-man have
you heard of anything more from no way
home marissa tomei has said a lot of her
scenes with john favreau were improvised
too but we have yet to find out what
those moments were what's your favorite
improvised moment from the movies let us
know in the comments and thanks for
watching